just take us through the map as it's
looking at the moment
russian advances they've certainly
slowed in the last couple of weeks but
but you can see that pattern can't you
of of them trying to join up the areas
that they do control yeah i think we're
seeing from your reports i mean fighting
continues in the country but from a
strategic perspective um the russian
forces around kiev seem to be more
digging in at the moment they seem to be
more consolidating probably resupplying
uh et cetera
but we're seeing around the donbass
region to the east there and mario poll
some intensely fierce fighting and i
think um that that's going to continue
for for the time being i think
strategically though as well the initial
deployment of 150 000 russian troops
appears to have stalled now
and there's either a stored or an
operational pause and when things like
that happen there are windows of
opportunity for negotiation to happen
because negotiations have only happen if
both sides see some benefit in talking
rather than continue to prosecute the
war um so there's a faint glimmer of
hope maybe of some some progress there
so that that's the hope from the talks
but but on the ground you know it
appears that president putin is
essentially just trying to split up
ukraine to try to to sort of shave off
this particular bit yeah there's a lot
of speculation about this and what what
are the um starting point for
negotiation and we can only speculate on
that i think kiev remains a strategic
priority for putin but i think given the
outstanding ukrainian resistance in
mario paul that's probably a step too
far in the near term um
certainly russia has invested a lot of
its military in the donbass region for
many years and therefore focusing on
that to secure that and also this land
bridge from crimea to russia mario paul
stands in the way so i think we can
expect to see an intensification of
activity there and that creates a a line
on a map
which might form putin's start point for
negotiation i'd be very surprised if
zelinski agrees with that line
and you know we're talking about lines
on maps but but these are people's homes
these are people's communities and and
people's lives and as we saw at alex's
report you know what's happening on the
ground is still dreadful yeah and i
think um one thing that sometimes gets
forgotten when that we're talking about
strategic lines on maps is mario pole
has been absolutely flattened as have
many other uh towns and cities in um in
ukraine and the people have had their
lives devastated it's cost them their
homes their livelihoods their families
their children um it's very difficult to
see how they will accept a random line
on a map and become subjugated to russia
which creates a a real problem i mean
there are precedents for this in finland
in the sort of 1940s when um the former
soviet union attacked and eventually
finland seeded about nine percent of its
territory in order to secure its freedom
but it's very difficult to see how that
would work in this situation i think the
real challenge though from my
perspective and from the west
perspective is whatever the negotiation
holds how does
zalenski secure security for ukraine
twice in the last eight years he's been
invaded by russia twice that putin has
lied to him about that and although
russia hasn't the russian forces haven't
performed particularly well on this
invasion and ukraine has done an
outstanding job
russia will learn they'll learn from
this experience in another eight years
they'll be much better equipped for for
for fighting so how does you know
zelinski secure his country one of the
ways of doing that being talked about is
neutrality the trouble is that sounds
like neutering it sounds like being
helpless and therefore creating a a
vulnerable country which is not
something that i think um silence would
be happy with and it would rely on
putin's word it would rely on trusting
his his word which is very hard to see i
think we can surmise that zelensky is
carrying a huge weight of responsibility
of history on his shoulders whilst
there's also nato and the eu countries
and i think from a strategic perspective
zelensky and ukraine find themselves at
the front line
of a global battle between democracy and
autocracy and those two tectonic plates
where they join
it's very hard to see there's not going
to be friction well indeed an earthquake
indeed sean bell thanks very much